good morning Millennials welcome back to
the morning toast
welcome back what a crazy weekend it was
getting drunk for you guys on patreon oh
my god feeling the effects the video of
our drunk get ready with me went up
yesterday on our patreon channel which
is wwh ENCOM slash the morning tous and
i would say it's going viral within the
patriarchy you know i think it is true
there's never been such you know
positive usually when we do an episode i
was like love this and maybe even like
they always give like a little shade
like love this mean next time you know
there was no next time here yeah 50
minutes of premium content us getting
drunk getting ready with us this snacks
are shows up we did a little lover
taylor swift commentary yeah and then we
were just drunk and having fun and then
we went to the squeeze concert where we
were like bombed and had a great time
and we were tempted by the fruit of
another i'm not gonna and jackie is
still feeling the effects yeah the shot
get ready with me yeah because i can't
remember probably not in like two years
probably not since my 25th birthday have
i like taking shots like aggressively in
order to get drunk like now I drink and
I happen to get drunk you know we'll see
where the night takes me but I haven't
drank like that like aggressively drank
so that I'm drunk in a long time and
it's it's not sitting well with me I
woke up yesterday with such a horrible
headache at eight o'clock like I didn't
know what to do with myself saying god I
fell back to sleep till 1:00 and they
just laid in bed all day I did something
new for me where I watched two good
movies like quality films the Coen
Brothers ever heard of them yes no I
watched a movie called Burn After
Reading okay which was decent I'm
actually called the what's it called
when you're like a spy for the CIA
the informant mmm-hmm decent but what I
was gonna say it's like I have the
opposite drinking pattern of you like I
never like drink to sip like I pound
shots like you'll never see me walking
around with the tequila soda I actually
hate like a warm melted icy drink in my
hand I'll just go to the bar take a
couple shots it gets me where I need to
be and then I'll come back like an hour
later for more I hate the concept of
like drinking gin I mean yeah I I do
understand I have the opposite
experience but I understand
what you are saying it's like that
freezing like sloshy you can hug anyone
you get like slashing people chirps yeah
and the condensation drips off the
driver I get a drink I just chug it so I
can just put it down because I just hate
it so I think you should i phone it's
just annoying yes why does two shots
well like usually when I drink the next
day I feel like a piece of [ __ ] like a
loser lowlife what have you done to
yourself but yesterday was interesting
because I had been drinking for my job
so I didn't feel that way it was like I
guess I worked really hard you worked
overtime actually get paid extra this
week I was like I'm working so hard no
the best types of hangovers are the ones
that eliminate the moral hangover I
actually think I would rather have a
physical hangover then a moral hangover
where like you really regret something
you said or did like that is the worst
and that makes the physical so much
worse so I think I can deal with the
physical there's many remedies there's
Pedialyte there's so many electrolytes I
could deal with that I don't think I can
deal with like the the regret well
yesterday I had the physical not the
moral because like I said I was working
like sorry and was it better than than
an average hangover um I don't for some
reason it was really painful and I drink
like we drink wine like I get drunk like
we went to Vegas like we do everything
and I haven't had like a painful
hangover like that in a while so I don't
know what the difference was but it was
painful maybe you didn't know
preparation before like what you do to
your body before hangover can actually
make an impact on Sunday perhaps I guess
I could have done better but you know
what was worth because the video is
hilarious everyone loved it
so I'll just continue to destroy my body
for you guys I had really a wonderful
experience yesterday well Ben left
yesterday morning early to drive his
sister to college and at like noon he
texted me that they were at a rest stop
and he had a possible burger for Burger
King and he said it was so good and then
I got like so in the mood for like road
food so I did something crazy and I knew
Burt eats McDonald's which if you know
me is not crazy for me at all and I
really got it like the order was based
around the fountain soda like I just
wanted to found soda so bad but I'm like
am I gonna please Turner from McDonald's
and I got a french fry I'm looking at
french fries without chicken nuggets so
I ended up getting an entire meal and I
sat down to eat it and it was regular
coke Wow it was like literally the worst
moment of my life like not to be
Germanic like I would have rather any of
the other items be ruined except for the
soda like and that was a whole
reason I did the order like I was
heartbroken I was gonna like write a
thing in the new breeds like message so
upsetting it was devastating I'm sorry
sis
terrible terrible sorry that happened to
you how's doctor for teman he's alive
and well um he had a crazy makin him and
i went to the park yesterday Olivia came
over and she was she called me she was
like I'm gonna go for a run in the park
like you I'm gonna take that so nice and
then she came over and I just felt like
a piece of [ __ ] like giving my son to
Olivia so she can take him like I just
felt awful so I put on leggings and a
sports bra and I said can we walk and
she said of course and obviously when
when I'm in charge we just sat in the
park on a patchy grass but who's nice
because I love you it wasn't Lana and we
caught up a bunch and then she made me
lunch so really turned into like a big
that day when it was mostly like a
healthy day that's what happens when you
invite me places and that was when you
ordered me Thomas yeah yeah that was
Helena for me the healthy I mean I was
really like eager to go on the walk
because I just had McDonald's you know
yes I understand but it was a lovely day
really you know the park is just quite
underrated actually I think I think
that's incredibly overrated I think a
lot of people like thoroughly enjoying
and maximize yeah but what I was getting
is that like everyone in the park wasn't
from New York you know it's like it's a
sightsee and so that's why people from
New York hate it because there's so many
tourists but I just wanted like there's
something so beautiful about Central
Park and you you walk in and you feel
like you remember every movie it's ever
been in you know any because they really
capture and it's so green and like
there's so many buildings and like it's
really beautiful I highly recommend it
Unger next trip to New York or if you
live here today's episode is brought to
you by Central Park kidding
Wow what a horrible way to start the
week for me like I'm just I feel so
tired but usually the show invigorate
think I'm feeling invigorated just in
the mean of six minutes we've had here
it's only been a mere six minutes and
we're invigorated you ever put on an
eyebrow gel that's like so adhesive like
it's doing its job so well then you
can't cross her eyebrows yeah and it's
great it's a Botox yeah she's not I
don't want to like dispel Kylie but her
brow gel is like literally Elmer's glue
and I can't move my eyebrows sounds like
a dream yeah my eyebrows have been
moving out of control recently it's time
for a Botox it's time and thing is like
what happens with me is like I don't
when my eyebrows start moving it's not
like they cause wrinkles it's like it
looks like there's like all these balls
under my skin yes
they look like nerdy you know what I
mean where it's like I SWAT like I got I
stuck balls at my nose and they make you
know in the kid in classes yeah that
like a magnet and then he had like a
little ball in his forehead no and then
he had to go to the nurse's office well
I do think we are due for some Botox
maybe a little lip filler what else
should we get done oh so are you guys
gonna do lips again I want to but
they're minor actually had a place that
I really like so I don't need them yet I
don't know I mean there was a period
where me and Margo looks so stupid like
so stupid I felt stupid for like putting
this in my body like it was my choice
you know what I mean and the thing with
lip fillers is that I like them but so
they last like three or four months
until you have to go do it again and
only for like the last two months do I
like what it looks like I'm enduring two
months of like hating the way that I
look and I already hated the way I
looked before so like why don't I just
save myself the time and money and just
not do it you know I hear that well I
love it you guys but you also do look at
now said whatever you're doing just
don't do it but this is the remnants but
then I see in my time huh I used to go
to my time up and see my chin and I
would like want to die now I go on my
time off and I see my chin and my lips I
guess I really never realized how small
my lips were and I don't ever want to go
back to that place but I don't know I
mean it's like it's mortifying how small
my lips were like I look like I am a
mouse I trying to eat some cheese you
know like my lips is like mousey they're
so [ __ ] small I won't do it again I
will not be that girl I will not be that
Mouse I refuse okay okay yeah so it's
something to think about but maybe
there's some other procedure I'd be
interested in you know every time I go
she's like recommending stuff I'm like
no I need like a full menu
I won't look that that facial where
they're like take off a layer of her
skin I yeah I don't know
I need I do need a facial but I can't
find a facialist in New York cities and
that weird it's incredibly weird I got a
facial when we were on our trip to Palm
Beach they're like I'm sorry like not
like I'm where they put lotion on your
yes and move it around like I need
someone to extract my skin and like well
so I went in there being like okay I'm
gonna endure the pain and so she
extracted so much and she said do you
want this hyaluronic acid extra peel
it's like an extra 50 I'm like yeah sure
oh my god I could have died I felt like
my entire face she must have put like a
real asset on my face I thought it was
dying [ __ ] I'm Sagat from one to ten
what's the pain like I'm like a ten okay
good like no [ __ ] that's not what I
suppose
get the [ __ ] off my face no spa facial
it doesn't count no no I want dr. facial
yeah I think you don't have a PhD to
give me when I go to LA I have someone
okay I'll get that I want to go to we
need to plan LA Weekly I know I know we
keep talking about it but now it's time
I know but you know us it's like so hard
for us upon anything in advance like the
life is just so crazy
you know getting away from us yeah Joe
Smith says she only plans her life six
months in advance that's a really long
time but I guess when you're like a
billion dollar business like you can
afford to be like scheduled I guess like
no you should be scheduled you can't
afford to be not nothing yeah one time
Dana made us buy tickets to a show over
a year in advance and it was just like
mind-blowing for me it's like I don't
even have the planner where I can write
this in right he wasn't showing Amy
Schumer and MSG and yes we wound up
going okay how was it it was really good
the tickets were a [ __ ] Dana but like we
had the worst [ __ ] seats in the house
like nosebleed on the Amy's left side
like Oh God not even Center nosebleed
right like left and so we bought them
over here in advance like there was
definitely tons of seats and she ends up
filming it as a special so if you just
stayed at home you could have had such a
better is the point of buying them so
far in advance if we didn't even get
good seats no I don't know so that's
something to think about Tina that
sounds like you while you're planning
your wedding why don't you think like
that it sounds like you need a new
planner sounds like I need a new friend
yeah okay um time I think so ten minutes
feels like time counts feels like time
counts further ado here are the fast
five stories that you need to know
before you wake up and take a bite out
of your morning toast that there were um
today's episode is brought to you by pin
your life Jackie please tell me about
your experience using Pete your life
because all you can do is smile when you
talk about it it's true I love paint
your life because it's this company
where you send them a photo that you
want them to transfer into like a
painting so I send like a wedding photo
of mine where I was looking like
particularly beautiful but also so the
background was beautiful so they go
ionic like repainting my hoof uh-oh
thanks Zach and I under in like a
silhouette and I just think it's so cool
because it's different than having just
a blown-up photo but you know I do
sometime
but this is just a little more artistic
they can paint anything and not only
will they paint it for you but you get
to go back and forth with the artist and
really putting your creative input like
ooh like my nose looks a little big
they're like mmm double chin like can
you just nice
so I think the whole experience plus the
end result is just incredible and we
would love to tell you more about it
he's an original painting of yourself
your children family a special place or
a cherished pet CEO at a price you can
afford from paint your life calm this is
a true painting done by hand by a
world-class artist created from a
favorite photo makes the perfect gift or
a birthday for birthdays or
anniversaries you choose the artist who
you work whose work you most admire and
work with them throughout the process
every detail is worked through until it
is perfect there's no risk if you don't
love the final painting your money is
refunded it's great for Dacor it's a
work of art with paint your life you get
your favorite memories transformed into
a work of art that you will cherish
forever it makes it truly special gift
for someone you love or for yourself
also I was one of those people who
almost had like a live artist at my
wedding like sitting in the corner
painting the wedding as is happening and
it was $2,000 and I just couldn't get
myself to pay that amount of money for
like a canvas so this seems like a
really like much more efficient way of
getting that done because then you have
the painting forever and you didn't have
to spend too much you know to take up
the space at your wedding of a man
sitting there with real easily Ben's
cousin can't even come you think this
lady's coming right now for a limited
time offer get 30% off your painting
that's right 30% off and free shipping
to get this special offer text the word
toast to 47 47 47 that's tio ast two
four seven four seven four seven again
for 30% off plus free shipping that's
tio ast 2 47 47 47 message and data
rates they might apply they may we just
we haven't need to tell you that yet I'm
not trying to get sued over here okay
first story a little fun news a little
throwback news Lizzie McGuire is getting
a reboot very exciting very exciting
this has been apparently in the works
for a while according to Lizzie herself
and the crew was supposed to they're
supposed to be there I hear Miranda
Gordo
Ethan craft is that his name yeah what's
the other one these Robert Kraft son
Kate Sanders oh she was such a [ __ ]
like honestly they named Judy Greer to
play her
like I wanted to just do a cameo episode
where I show Kate Sanders that it's okay
to be an alpha repeater you know that
really is my [ __ ] cross to bear it's
like she made me feel so low for being
someone who repeats outfits when
honestly I think it is so important to
repeat outfits like you spend money time
energy on these wardrobe choices wear
them again
speaking of ironically I am where war
drobe repeating today with the shirt
that I wore to speak to Hilary Duff's
cast member Peter Herman exactly say
what goes around comes back around here
are the deeds from enews a source that
we will cite kate sanders is so
yesterday 15 years after an entire
generation of Millennials bid a tearful
farewell to lizzie mcguire disney
revealed the Cheras teen sitcom is
officially getting a reboot and Hilary
Duff will replac reprise the titular
character the series which will stream
exclusively on Disney Plus will catch up
with Lizzie as she takes on adulthood in
the Big Apple is this younger oh my god
totally dump celebrated the announcement
at Disney's d3 Expo on Friday night wait
I have an amazing idea telling enews it
was quote near impossible to keep it all
a secret I'm a fan and we're such a part
of each other it makes a lot of sense
and feels really right okay so a kid you
think she's deaf Mary and maybe wait
hold on I feel like the best way for
this to happen is Lizzie grows up in New
York and it fuses with younger and it
turns out that Kelsey has been lying
because we need a new lie
younger the lie I'm a that's a really
good idea Liza is old and stale and
that's the premise of the show and now
they don't know what to do we just were
watching the new season and it's like
what are we gonna do here yeah so they
should have Kelsey be living in
elaborate like where she's really Lizzie
McGuire she was one of her to know how
famous she was when she was a kid yeah
love that love that and now also this
just gives me hope that like maybe one
day Hannah Montana will be right think
Miley would never this is so great you
know
Miley like like if you say Miley would
never like him then she wants to do it
you know so we she just keep saying
it'll never happen cuz she just likes to
prove people wrong is never gonna do it
she'll never do it every don't even hold
your breath she'll die with no more
breath audience for one-hitter like
being talked over like three times in a
row all I was trying to say was a really
person piece of information
which is that this is where the
streaming wars are benefiting the
consumers it's like we'd like to live
with [ __ ] Netflix content for the
past five years because it's the only
streaming service out there that's
making original content but now we have
the new HBO we have the new Warner we
have all these programs that are just
throwing money at Gossip Girl bewitched
listen McGuire payments and finally the
consumer is benefiting yeah because it's
forcing all of these streaming platforms
to be better and they can't just rest on
their laurels
they can't just like pretend that that
show you and I with Penn Badgley is good
because we all know it wasn't really but
we're living in a time where there's no
content so we're like oh okay this is
good
but it's not you know and they can't
just like throw Marvel superhero content
at us all day yeah I'm sorry I know a
lot of people love it but a lot of
people don't give a [ __ ] yeah and two of
them are standing right here
unless it's jessica jones which by the
way he's he's done that was the series
finale the one marble show I liked it's
like it wasn't even good nobody actually
for sure it made you think sure anyways
I totally agree this is really like an
arms race of streaming platforms it's
like all the different spike Seltzer's
now coming out it's like this benefits
the consumer yeah what level of spike
seltzer would you like what flavor like
you can really find your own niche right
and I'm just here for it it's like for
so long it has had a monopoly on on the
content streaming space it's really
honestly this is a little business
because it's really about economics and
you know everyone trying to be their
best to capitalize the market and it
benefits the consumer and so I'm here
for it that's like I literally I'm
having a flashback to sitting in dr.
Stone's history class when he was
talking about like what a monopoly is
and like how a government can like stop
a merger to think them having a monopoly
or whatever and he's like well
competition benefits the consumer and
this is the first time I've ever feeling
like competition is benefiting me as a
consumer no totally and it's like
sometimes I feel the government like
steps in and there's like a cap to the
competition like at a certain point
maybe a streaming service Disney
wouldn't be able to partner with like a
Warner right as this streaming would get
too big and that's when it doesn't help
us I feel like that's what happened with
the airline's
nobody cares about us anymore right when
the United and continental like they
just stopped trying to get better yeah
it's a delta really holds himself to a
higher standard but that means
higher prices Tuesday I lost my hair pop
but they have no air bubbles
count Fersen it you know it's not how
can they okay it fell out while I was
sleeping like where did it go
and I was at Delta's fault I looked and
there's to me Chris when do you land
there's a lot of impact so probably flew
to the back of a plane that is not Delta
smells to me Kravitz you should have
woken up when your air podcast fell out
of your ear he'll think I slept through
it i glitter Ibis ami transcontinental
flight and i slept through half of it so
it felt like a four hour flight is
incredible but I prefer to have to pay
the price of one Airport but I will say
the price of one air pad is $69 which
you can buy through Apple which I did
and so I didn't have to buy a whole new
air pod and then have like oh my gosh my
holder and I bought you could buy just a
holder too and finally my air pods are
reunited and I really it went so well
like it was easier than it should have
have any parts of your air pod like be
all over your house like one air pod
here the whole drove in there the air
pod in your bag is such a like a dis
comforting feeling because like you know
unless you have those three things back
together stat it is never gonna be a
renown it's never it's a horrible
feeling yeah here I know that throws
your air pods just in your bag without I
never do but like sometimes like if I'm
just feeling for klimt or like I'm
rushing to deplane or get on the plane I
just throw it in I'm like I'll get it
later and then they just have a way of
separating ya also sometimes what I do
you guys cautionary tale sometimes I'll
be sleeping on my tray table and the air
pod I'm wearing is hurting my ear so I
take it out pretty much still sort of
sleeping so I look for my bag and I drop
it in my bag I lost one air pod on the
divine diversion and like I said that
situation couldn't get any worse we were
diverted to Pittsburgh from Nashville
all we want to show is get home it was a
treacherous travel day next thing I know
air pod gone missing wow I didn't know
that it I found it but it made the whole
but like for an hour I thought that like
I wasn't gonna have my ear pods during
this incredibly treacherous time and I
just saw what my life would be like and
if I didn't have the air pod and it was
not a life I wanted to live also like
the divine version like really ruined
the greatest showmen reimagined album
for me because I listened to it came up
the next day while we were sitting in
Pittsburgh waiting to board her flight
when they like couldn't find a fly they
say we're shirking us around and I just
like now I have the memory of listening
to it like feeling so angry like CBS
level yeah
chess club machine machine angry and
that's just always how I feel about well
that's now how like it's an association
associated feeling I have with the CMA
Awards which is so sad because for two
years in a row it's been the best night
of my life and we got off of a high like
we had just partnered with Access
Hollywood they were so happy with us
like we were like we're going home to
like just roll into the weekend it's
like we're gonna step up the players
gonna be crabs yeah very hot ROTC like
we were really on a high and I just I
didn't foresee what that day had for us
like when we were sitting in the lounge
eating mac and cheese the Delta had the
most amazing mac and cheese do you
remember it I remember moments by food
yeah it was so delicious and I get a
notification from Dell said I'm sure
it's like Oh gate change flight cancels
and I'm like like I just I didn't eat
that moment I had no idea where I was
going at midnight that night yeah and
you know what I kind of had a a really
bad feeling and I thought we should go
back to the hotel um but but you did not
yeah and obviously I now know that
you're right about everything and if I
had known back then that I would have
come to learn that you were a soothsayer
and a clairvoyant one at that I would
have obviously listened to you but now I
wouldn't have felt the comfortable
making that call I would have been like
listen I know this didn't happen but we
have to wait it out because you can't
just like throw in the towel and go get
a room in Nashville like people are
places to go that was like such a hard
day for us the craziest part
listen flight that left before our hard
flight went into Pittsburgh but the
flight before us it was only once he
left and Claudia got it I was on standby
and we both were on semi and I got on
and Jackie did it and our NBC producer
producer got on the flight and I was
like so jealous of him
and I'm say I wasn't gonna leave Jackie
and Nashville so I let him go and I was
like so mad at him and like we were
sitting in Nashville and he texted us
like probably two and a half hours after
they left
now she'll say the flight to New York is
like three hours he was like we're
hovering over LaGuardia they're sending
us back to Nashville and they cruise
back to Nashville so at least we made it
further yeah and then and then I got on
the plane and I was like I heard this
plane just came from LaGuardia
ok there's but I had information that
maybe other people didn't have I'm like
hi I know someone who was on this plane
right before and he literally just
deplaned from Lou Ardea to Nashville
like they wouldn't let him get off and
there was a
tenant who literally was pointing at me
with a gate agent telling me like to
stop spreading like you know fear
amongst the passengers is conspiracy
theory that's what exactly what I was
doing
it's like that episode of friends like
there's something wrong with the left
bull Angie Margo I know you don't have
the last two episodes left and it's from
philosophy okay my man has been watching
friends like throughout like he was like
cleaning his stuff yesterday and like so
friends was just on in the background
and now I'm living with friends exciting
what a nice time for you to be alive
it's so bad so good have you sat down to
watch one we tried finish it no because
you like said you were done with me oh
my god you kept getting up I kept
getting up yeah I was like show me one
episode of friends that like you think I
will like and I had things to do so then
I thought of an episode that I really
have been holding on to for a while that
if you ever asked me that question it's
the one with the videotape where Ross
and Rachel find out like who came on to
him and I watched it really I was like
this is the episode I'm gonna make
Jackie watch and we're putting it on
she's getting up she's getting a drink
she's getting up she gets the door mames
comes she shows him the room I'm like
okay I want to go back to watching the
society I can't be bothered with
following you around all day sorry
ladies okay are you ready for our next
story yes now that Lizzie McGuire turned
into oh it because of capitalism and the
the competition of the airlines okay
next story is a two-parter because we
having some exciting bachelor news
first up the bachelorettes Rachel
Lindsay and Bryan a basil--oh are
married the former Bachelorette and
precious gem of current crushes gem of a
woman and her fiance who met on her
season of the show in 2017 exchanged
vows at the Royalton Suites Cancun in
Mexico on Saturday that is so great I
love them so much I believe in their
love I'm happy they're just like doing
the damn thing hahaha without like
they're not only beans thirsty like they
just got married because they wanted to
know totally I didn't even you know a
lot about the wedding this is actually a
really big deal because they're the
first outside from Ari and Lauren who
like had a shotgun wedding um they're
like the first bachelor couple to get
married in the in forever we never got
kilo each on Jojo and Jordan are
actually before proposing no but they're
before Rachel and Bryan oh yeah they're
still
and but they're actively planning the
wedding now because he we proposed yeah
they were searching that's gonna get
there and I'm really happy for them and
for a real success and are there any
other batch like so Nick was in between
them no are yes Ben Higgins no and
there's one other bachelor that we're
forgetting Oh call him
we'll see who's not even a game so yeah
like this should be a bigger deal like
someone made it down the altar y'all
and like they bachelor loved to they the
producers edited this so much to really
make us think that like Brian was a
consolation prize and after meeting them
and just like hanging out with him over
the past two years said this like so not
the case and I just want to mention that
Peter Krause liked our Instagram on the
morning toast of their wedding photo we
and he commented it on our drunk glam
getting ready promoting the patreon
saying ooh 42 like you know I'm there oh
my goodness Peter cross got me into
tequila he doesn't even know he no he's
just like commenting that he wanted an
invitation because he likes tequila
oh man I'm [ __ ] I just like I just want
to say like that there appears to be
absolutely no bad blood there none none
whatsoever and the bachelor and like
producers tried to make us think
otherwise but we could not be fault
quote Rachel was the epitome of elegance
and grace is she walked down the aisle
towards Brian the ceremony was filled
with so much joy love and laughter
wedding planner Michael Russo tells
people Oh Jackie is what I meant yeah
quote I said I set them up cute eyes
they exchanged their personal
handwritten vows you could feel the
unbridled emotion and powerful
connection between them that is so sweet
oh also we posted this picture of them
the bride and groom and everyone was
saying such mean things and I have to
say remember what I always say there's
two people there's places for Helen to
people but there's two people who can
find themselves a place in hell right
one men who call women fat or anyone who
thoughts a woman back and to someone who
says something mean about a bride on her
wedding day
like we said and stuff about Medicaid
Marco ok but when you're in like a
different stratosphere also we I don't
think we said anything mean all we said
was that her dress needed tailoring yeah
and like a steaming
yeah that's not mean we said that about
the dress not about her and people were
like this picture is so weird and I just
think it's worth noting that they they
posed in that particular way like with
their shoulders against each other
because they had to give this picture to
people before the wedding actually
started but they didn't want to see each
other before the ceremony so this was
the only way they could be in a picture
together and not see
each other which i think is really sweet
yeah everything so - really sweet and
that never happens anymore everyone
takes their pictures before the ceremony
resumes see each other for Jewish
weddings you have to see each other but
for non-jewish weddings like that's so
it's still so cool that you could
actually have that moment of seeing
someone when they come down the aisle
and I just love watching wedding videos
where they catch the groom when he's
watching the bride walk down that I own
they get all emotional I love it
beautiful I'm so happy for them me too I
love her I love her she's truly just
like a southern belle like she is just
so classy I feel like the wedding was
just a [ __ ] black-tie affair
you know no it looks fun some of her
fellow alums were there shellman Astrid
cute and Bibiana and Alexis
yeah alexis was Raven no and she wasn't
at the bachelorette party either oh
really that's so crazy because those
girls and when they came off their
season we're like ride-or-die best
friends I know and like I love Rachel
and I love right and Raven and Rachel
both lived in Dallas for a long time
like they were super close something
happened at that birthday party is these
passionate friendship no but at a party
Rachel wasn't mad at Raven raisers that
would've stayed oh yeah so it's
something we don't know oh my god I need
to find I have to be honest I don't want
to know because I don't want to feticide
because I love them both sometimes I
feel like Alexis like people could be in
the middle Isis Friends of both I think
okay so Michael when we went out in
Dallas who do we go out with Raven
Rachel and Alexis all of them right yes
so it was a year ago yeah that was in
February March that was most fun yeah oh
my god that that hurt that cuts deep
counts truly this is really upsetting I
didn't expect heartbreak before 11 a.m.
I know
10:58 okay well another bit of good news
bachelorettes Jordan Rogers took the
shadow plane repose to Jordan Fletcher
I'm sorry - Jojo Fletcher Fletcher like
taking the [ __ ] like gave him the
courage to do something else bold it's
like after Friday's episode it took a
massive jump and I felt just like Jordan
Rogers
yeah and so do you feel like like
renewing your vows exact
let's do it all this is a trend I feel
like in housewives when you renew your
vows it's like a bad it's a curse any
housewife that has renewed their vows on
TV has gotten divorced Mario and Ramona
there's Vicki and Donn there's just a
lot so kept not Kim and Kroy right but
they did just do it so it could still
happen okay so far things like reading
break the curse off so I think that like
the reap repose and bachelor nation is
like that curse because we remember
Shawn took Kaitlyn's ring and he was
gonna re-propose ever come back together
well he would be he was gonna be
proposed cuz they had been like fighting
and stuff and they look so many but and
she wasn't wearing her ring so many were
like they're broken up and they said no
we're repurposing but he didn't know so
I just think the whole concept right I
didn't know like this wasn't like a
planned thing I can just say the whole
concept might be a curse maybe but I I
think it's actually a sweet concept but
like why not get married right and get
married with a new ring like that's what
they wanted to do which by the way I
totally understand because her new ring
is a beautiful [ __ ] sick at least
Karen Foster
it's insane generally speaking Neil Lane
rings aren't my favorite yeah no me
neither but Marga when you sent me the
Instagram story that they had done it
and it was a picture of the ring I
thought you were sending me and they
were in foster at Simon's ring because
they look exactly the same like most
borderline copycat Wow
it's good for a copy and it's a gold
band ring is oval yeah
I love it it's beautiful it's all there
a chance so that's sweet I didn't
believe in their love at first I'm not
gonna lie but I think I've been
convinced and I've been proved wrong
agreed snatchler what's your take on
this as like the reggie resident jojo
Sam I'm a huge Jojo static says I can't
really look at them the same after the
after the into story like I just can't
because like I love her but I don't know
if I love him I know yeah but I'm happy
for her and like I just want I think
everything she does isn't as a part of
is amazing and I love her ring have you
watched her knee show know but it's
recorded so one day I'll I'll binge it I
just haven't gotten around to it I read
somewhere I know you're about to see
what am i reassure was meant for another
couple yeah and it didn't work out and
they just gave it to Jojo in Jordan
right
I read that somewhere it's like a slight
to Jordan judge about who cares they set
out their own TV show I would take a TV
show made for literally [ __ ] anyone
you know and especially on CNBC and
that's a death of the type of show they
wanted like they were obviously like
staying for a home renovation show with
all their Instagram stories so I think
it's great who cares that it was made
for someone else yeah but I guess like
the treatment of the show and like the
whole concept was built around these two
other people and it didn't end up
working out so they like last minute
filled in Jordan Jo Jo but I think I
heard they're doing a great job yeah I
love the other couple they're attempting
to like make her more I guess relatable
they're like wearing all these like
flannel shirts and like she's super glam
and on her season on The Bachelorette
like she had the best wardrobe she has a
[ __ ] clothing line and I feel like
she has it in her contract that she has
to wear flannel and it's like it's
annoying nobody know who she is like
don't try and make her something she's
not right like you can like you know
demo day in heels no we're like I don't
know an off-the-shoulder or something
yeah that's weird and I haven't watched
a show of it I can't imagine she's the
one like getting nitty like I feel like
she's the concept designer and Jordan is
like these she's doing right so she can
wear another function or whatever the
[ __ ] she wants I just know there was a
meeting where everyone liked and not her
sat around a table where they talked
about how she's like we need to make her
more you know of a down-home girl right
and I just wanna let you know like no
you don't
she's great the way she is and people
like a little glamour I know especially
in a home decor show yeah she has a
clothing line watch a really cute one -
how do you worn anything like some
things from fashion pass sweet cool okay
everyone's good on that yeah I'm feeling
okay I'm feeling sluggish today it's the
Randi masked man I feel like a lack of
taking care of myself a lack of drinking
water a lot of eating right like not
that I really ever exercise but it's
I've been so a mobile that I think it's
starting to like turn me into it like
like I have bed sores well what are you
gonna do about that says I'm gonna make
a positive change and I'm gonna head
over to open fit open fit takes all the
complexity out of losing weight getting
fit it's a brand new super simple
streaming service that allows you to
work out from the comfort of your living
room for as little as 10 minutes a day
you could sculpt your body in the
convenience of your own home without
eyes on you which is probably the
absolute worst part about going to the
gym is seeing other people
it's affordable and accessible if you're
going on vacation I'm worried that your
hotel won't have a gym you can look on
your computer your web an idol TV your
tablet your smartphone or even your Roku
you can literally take these these
workouts with you anywhere you get what
you put in so you'll see results within
the first 30 days if you want to just
increase your crease your energy put a
step and overall feel better inside
which is exactly what I want to do I
think this would be really good for an
agoraphobic like me you know mm-hmm open
fit has changed the way that we work out
and texting code toast to 30 30 30 you
can join us on our fitness journey
personalized just for you right now
during the open fit 30-day challenge our
listeners got a special extended 30-day
free trial membership to open fit when
you text toast to 30 30 30 you'll get
full access to open fit all the workouts
and nutritional information totally free
again text toast TOA st - 30 30 30
standard message and data rates may
apply sign-on workout in private sign-on
feel no shame
okay by the way the person who said the
thing about the show being for someone
else was Chad Johnson mmm so take it
with a grain of salt I was about to say
nt yet it's like you got like a blind
yet I'm actually that makes perfect
sense if you ever cook about that crazy
twit
attend a Twitter tirade that Chad
Johnson went on and some of them are
really offensive but some one of them
was hilarious which one
sorry Wells Adam so your first name is
really Adam and your last name as well
sorry but all been pronouncing it wrong
really funny yeah I wish we got an inch
of it because actually it's irrelevant
now and I hate to give people like that
like the time the judges there's an
interesting claims if we are it was just
out here like saying people were gay
and like he's just an actor I'm like
crystalling goose and like yeah I think
to give that stuff any like levity okay
next up Taylor Swift's lover is the only
needed two days to become 2019
best-selling album in the US okay date
that was just that was just really sunny
news is that Taylor Swift lover has
officially surpassed star is born'
sales wow this is one amazing news for
Taylor Swift but two incredibly
interesting news about the album
industry in this country because clearly
I would sales like there has been no
competitor in this year no there hasn't
and what's what it really took the album
industry by storm is obviously streaming
and in the past few years like if you
actually looked up the numbers without
like top-selling albums actually sold
it's a lot less than you think and
Taylor has been like this benchmark
where every time she releases an album
it hits a millions
and that was like that is her own like
gold that she said her for herself but
also for the industry like I think the
only other people to kind of compare
like Adele yeah so everyone was webbing
that sec she gonna hit her own mark
again and she doubled it so now she's
had two million sales in the first week
whereas she set like the industry record
for being 1 million yes like how crazy I
wonder what change like why are more
people buying now then no it's important
to note that I don't want to rain on
your parade but Republic Records had
global consumption not sales and not
domestic us I don't care about domestic
so it's not today include streams and
yeah so the numbers aren't really out
yet I read somewhere that her new album
is shreem friendly because it's so long
that's what artists are doing now it's
not even about like how many listens
like the more songs that are on the
album the better it will do streaming
wise oh interested you're forcing people
if you want to listen to the whole album
you have to stream more hours of Taylor
Swift well what's so funny is I was
reading as many a review this week and I
have to say like the real music
magazines at Rolling Stone billboard
like ones that are respected in the
music industry they really respect the
hell out of Taylor Swift and you don't
expect like Rolling Stone to be like
saying such nice things about pop star
Taylor [ __ ] but they really respect her
and then I was reading like articles by
like freaks who know nothing about music
like Cosmo and they were just saying
mean things about Taylor because they
didn't want to be like so I don't know
the girl who wrote it and they don't
know like what Kosmos relationship with
Taylor is like but it's obviously they
just wanted to like to have something
controversial for the sake of not being
like we love Taylor Swift and the girl
made the dumbest literally the dumbest
on accusation just being like Taylor
Swift hasn't grown up at all she's still
writing songs about high school and
Taylor released a whole thing about how
Americana and the heartbreak prints like
it sounds like it's a song about high
school but it's like it's putting like
the politics of America in a
metaphorical high school yeah and like
this girl didn't even do it like if
you're gonna write an out like a an
article about Taylor Swift or just about
anything the do your research she
literally put out what the song is about
and you're over you're cleaning that
it's about something else I mean I just
felt like she gets such unfair treatment
from like mainstream like like pop
culture outlets because they just want
to be cool and different you know well
Kosmos been insane going after Taylor
like I don't know what they have tried
to get her on the cover and she was like
oh
yes she would never I don't know what
they have so below yeah no I mean she's
on the September issue of though like
I'm sorry Cosmo it's just not gonna cut
it but you know I'm it's just it's just
so interesting how like music industry
people like really respect Taylor yeah
the business side of it you do have to
CBS this morning yeah it was really good
yeah
I actually I watched the trailer for the
reputation to are on Netflix last night
which really made me feel like I watch
the whole thing yeah and it made me
really excited for the lover tour
because it's gonna be like like you're
walking into a cotton candy machine yeah
yeah good dream like my HIPPA right if
you think she needs if she takes the
level of design from reputation to lover
but instead of everything being black at
being pink like it will be like it's yet
just like the branding for reputation
was like just its was great and it was
like every single thing lined up made
sense like had this from the microphones
to the set to the design to the cosmic
bonds yeah had this theme to it and now
she's done the same sort of branding
with lover but an opposite completely
different and it's just gonna be like an
amazing experience I'm really just like
I I really want the rumors of it to
being a non stadium tour to be false I
really want it to be a stadium oh I
would love if it wasn't a stadium tour
but she I don't think she would ever do
that it's definitely gonna be a stadium
tour even in the title for a reputation
movie it's Taylor Swift's reputation
stadiums like she wants everyone to know
that she's playing state you know it's
[ __ ] sick literally she's like one of
the only women heard Beyonce to ever
sell out like some of the stadium said
she's going to she's the first woman to
perform there like literally in ten
years yes I don't know why she would
give that up and you make more money and
she's done a good job where I never
heard the complaint that you don't feel
like you see enough of the show she goes
all the way around yes one's gonna get
that complaint it's gonna be Ariana
Grande yeah because she was she was in
again on stage yeah but she's just a
little yeah I love her me too she you
just see I know did you see there's a
big drama going around but it's not that
big of a deal so basically she performed
at Manchester pride and it was like this
big important moment cuz she's only
performed once since the the terrorist
attack and that was at the Manchester
one love
so she performed hit pride and they
released the schedule and she was only
performing for 35 minutes so people were
like super upset about that and then
they closed the doors for entry at 7
o'clock and people were like hundreds
thousands of people were like outside
the doors who had bought tickets for her
waiting and unable to get in but I think
for security reasons they closed the
doors at 7:00 but I don't know if people
were given proper notice as to when the
doors were closing so people in Twitter
were up in arms there was like whole
Twitter memories thing about it that's
really annoying but it's not all round
Grande's fault no I wouldn't let her
know and we even New York cried like
went so behind schedule like these
things just happen but and you know what
there's just so many people that want to
be there and that's like a good problem
it's a great problem to have but it
sucks for people who paid money yeah and
didn't get and then they said didn't
have a screen outside like for you to
watch the performance that you paid for
and are currently missing yeah no that's
what you do wrong no it's like it was
this guy just somewhere yeah howarth
repeating she didn't do anything wrong
but I was gonna say she's been really
quiet like pursue her personal life
which is good which is what we want from
her so I hope right now wherever she is
she's like having a good time she's me
to her i all say no but like music was
she's always tweeting something or like
there she's in the news anything it's
been a few weeks of us not talking about
her which no news is good news
and are you like I hope you're right
unless we don't forget you literally
really sits around two weeks ago yeah
but I actually feel like she might be
being quiet on purpose because she's
been like the Queen of Pop for the last
year um and now with Taylor coming out
with me music like I don't think they
want to compete with each other I don't
think they really can compete with each
other so I think it's like Queens
letting Queens have their moment that's
actually what I think it is I agree and
I and I don't think Scooter Braun wants
to put out music from Ariana at the same
time as Taylor because Taylor is a
stream Queen she's yeah just Ariana's
thank you next sales because I was just
curious because I really album stood
thank you next sell 360 so crazy that
was the one of the biggest albums of the
year but when Taylor Swift is the
benchmark like you don't realize so many
people but ariana grande is really a
stream queen like she yeah she's really
like
the New Age pop diva like lover she did
that same and so did me like where she
debuted on YouTube and I don't think she
beats thank you next viewership I don't
know I don't think she didn't think so
so we're like seven like so Ariana's
like really I guess it's crazy to say
that Taylor's more of like old-school
right artists you know what Taylor has
cemented herself in wanting someone to
like buy your album instead of 70% but
so on the one hand you say like they
can't even compete with each other and
it's like the argument the argument
could be made on both sides that Taylor
camp can't compete in like Ariana's
world of like putting out music like um
like a rapper almost where it's just
like this is how I feel this is what's
going on right now
Taylor is so like premeditated and
they're both great at what they do but
they're so different and in certain ways
like one's better than the other not
that we're pitting women against each
other me two movies are defend Taylor
today like it's just inner no chess I
you know what I love the album I love a
few of the songs and I'm really excited
for this era congratulations girls your
girl came through for you you know what
it's it I've ever seen that with I feel
at home in the studio tipsy ZURB and I
just have found that like I'm always
just like out here defending Taylor to
like not even just to you just like to
anyone and it really like a hurts my my
soul and I'm just I don't like I'm tired
but I'm saying like right you defend
Taylor when she needs defending and like
she just put out a great album she needs
no defending and you should be excited
about that
no seriously seriously counts like when
she put out those singles and I was like
this ain't it ladies and you were pissed
and I'm saying this is it this is it
cool what's your favorite song on the
album today summer and afterglow okay
yeah - some fun news inside Sophia's
Ritchie's epic epic 21st birthday party
in Las Vegas with Scott Disick and Kylie
Jenner
Wow we know yeah yeah parts of news
ladies oh happy birthday Sofia Richie
the model turned 21 on Saturday and
celebrated with her boyfriend of two
years Scott Plus Kylie and mutual
friends Stas Greece Palmer Victoria the
Arroyo and assistant it seems like Sofia
has no friends because all the people on
this trip are carly's Francis and their
bread it's the same group of people from
Kylie's birthday i Finch like I love it
mucho like she's a full-blown sister and
I love that and I was watching Sophia
stories and first of all she's another
one like Haley Baldwin I don't think I
ever heard her voice before no it's a
Shea's very low voice and I was watching
their stories and we got to see like a
little more of her personality I didn't
see Kylie so I'm just finding out now
that Kylie was there did she leave I
thought the same thing so Kylie story
when they were all on the jet to Vegas
she was like that's a favorite you were
waiting for you like blah blah blah she
was on the plate and then after that I
did not seen her in Vegas okay she
probably just left early like I don't
know if it's time to go to the day party
after spend the night as a child you
know what they did they throw that for
him after the nightclub wait that is
like my dream they had all these like
talentless so happy birthday Sofia
pajamas waiting for them I'm like the
nicest jet ever and that girl in the
cowboy hat she looks like a good time
yeah Amber's oh that's amber Ashley you
know what like I can't decide if getting
my own jet to take me home after the
club is amazing or not it's so not she
said what if you're like full blackout
like gotta throw up like and you're on a
plane that's perfect if you're full
blackout you don't remember being on the
plane and you wake up in your bed what a
waste of a private jet not remembering
being on it I don't know that's truly
the dream that's really like what I
think what I want to cross to bear but
also like this Sunday like a little post
Adele's brunch jet like that sounds nice
I wonder why they didn't say that's so
crazy like they all like don't have
enough time of their schedules to like
yeah more like one day see those girls
don't even have jobs yeah or like they
have Instagram jobs which allow you to
you know which I give you're in Vegas
it's better for take your picture I just
yeah yeah I don't know but it looked
really fun and I'm just so happy for
like I love I love this crew I love
their love and I wonder why Kendall
like dude like do those things with them
well I think out of all the sisters
Kendall and Courtney are like some of
the closest and maybe it would feel not
like a betrayal but just like better not
oh because it is we're it is weird that
like but Carly and Sophia were friends
before and they're the same age but she
stopped being friends it's like they
stopped being friends because the
relationship was like not kosher and it
was it was no one was gonna endorse it
but then clearly after more than a year
of being together Courtney's okay with
it and she probably said to the girls
like listen like we're all quote with
Sophia now like you can talk to her and
Kylie like Greg went from zero to 100
like Kourtney probably didn't expect
that their friendship would become like
this yeah but but she said that they
could be friends again and Kendall and
Kourtney are really so tight yeah that
Kourtney could confide in Kendall just
really please don't go yeah that's what
I imagine happened I know it must really
suck I know it's crazy
I do but I like I ship Kourtney I mean I
ship Kylie and Sophia Hawaii to see a
friend who's also family that's not
gonna betray her right like because
technically Sophia couldn't hook up with
Tristan Thompson because it would
weirdly be like incest ya know and also
I just think like Sophia growing up the
way that she did she definitely
understands their lifestyle a little bit
more than someone who has just brought
into it you know yeah like Jordan and
even Stas like these girls didn't grow
up like this like they don't know like
the importance of family and like what
the loyalty means I'm like Sophia grew
up just as famous is that like yeah
arguably her dad was more fish she's
gonna but more famous and so I think
that having that type of background
definitely is like a value that Kylie
like laughs and I just can't believe
that Sophia wasn't 21 like I know and
she posted the funniest thing on her
story because I gave Grubman like story
for her birthday and she was like now I
can go to the club and not have to
pretend like I'm the DJ otherwise she
could get it in yeah that's so crazy
it's just like nuts how like fast you
grow up in Hollywood like Sophia Richie
and my mind is 50 years old no she's at
least 25 first yeah it's so crazy
yeah and finding out celebrities ages
it's like the most shock where they
think you know mm-hmm a cardi B being 24
that is crazy good job where the movie
hustlers permanent cuz you're doing so
much press for it let it come
I know they're promoting it for so long
we got JLo we got constants whoo
keke palmer cardi B and really Reinhardt
and I just have a feeling it's gonna be
a terrible movie
yeah when whatever Ghibli movies JLo
touches like actually turns I saw her
newest movie second chance it's good was
on sale on iTunes for a 99 cent rental
like that's like movies from the 80s
I like second act I didn't see it I just
feel like her her acting is just like
not it no I agree and what's crazy is I
feel like the movie hustlers was just
just filmed it's like they're really
turning it around like quickly quicker
than a season of Vanderpump rules a
Riverdale right yeah yeah it's just like
everyone should be stepping up their
game for that I want to support it yeah
Miccio and also I just want to like
support Lilly Ryan are becoming like a
mega movie stars yeah all of her
classmates hate her ya know like she was
on the cover of Wonderland or whatever
and screaming [ __ ] JLo , did it yeah
so if she was wearing those white go-go
yeah I saw I saw
I was upset but I'm glad that she got to
wear them yeah do you sure to keep them
yes if she wanted to maybe maybe like
they would let her buy them at discount
but like I don't think you just got to
keep stuff I think you do actually I
don't think it's as fun as it seems no I
don't show the magazine has to borrow it
like they don't buy it
mm-hmm they then we're gonna shoot once
and I didn't get to keep the jumpsuit
cuz I asked it needs to be accounted for
you I think if you get the brand's
approval like I like the stylist asked
the brand if I could keep it and they
said yeah I'm sure if like they asked
Fendi but you have to really have loved
them yeah it's something to think about
for sure okay the final story is a
little space news and a little space
drama a little speech Emma news but
Shemin news interesting NASA astronaut
deny space crime accusations I'm the
names bitter divorce battle it's the
first time that there's space crime
potential what choice diction does space
fall under it's an interesting thing
decorated NASA astronaut and MacLean has
denied she stole her estranged wife's
identity while on a mission as officials
investigate her for what may be the
first crime committed in space its
astronaut on astronaut crime in Italy
bit its astronaut on civilian great
quote
unequivocally no truth to these claims
McLean said Saturday on Twitter McLain
we've been going through a painful
personal separation that's now
unfortunately in the media
McLean's legal drama made headlines
Friday after her wife summer warden
filed a complaint with the FTC claiming
the astronaut illegally accessed her
bank account during a six-month mission
abroad the International Space Station
the New York Times reported but the hell
did that lady need her money for in
space they don't have ATMs there because
they're divorcing so maybe she like
wanted to get in there and move some
stuff around maybe she thought she could
have be prosecuted because she's on
space-time honestly that was a really
brilliant way she did it during her
space she did it while she was insane
Howard did she even get in contact with
the they got a technology up there so
she probably just think logged in do you
did Wi-Fi in this I think so because I
have to get back down to her they have
to report back because that's a radio I
don't know she did it and it's you ever
see how women have to pee in space yeah
there's a whole thing about it it's so
in equal what it is how men pay is so
much different than have women big thing
about it without gravity doesn't it come
back you know you have to like section
like for a man you could like stick your
pee-pee in like a bottle or something
yeah and like capture it in there yes
what does woman do it could just be like
freefall you know so what is it what's
again same with pooping like the pellets
could just speaking of suction did
anyone watch a new season of 13 reasons
no no I'm not gonna spoil anything but
there's two moments I really want to
talk about and new closures it doesn't
make a difference but someone it's it's
not a spoiler but it's playing music in
here oh good I play toast look yeah just
do it fast
okay wait can you wait like four seconds
four three two one cruel summer okay so
in one of the episodes a girl has an
abortion and I just thought the way they
filmed it was like really like
breathtaking like I we they basically
had us there the whole time like while
the procedure like you saw the Machine
and it was so sad this girl was like so
young and afraid and it was just like
really shocking and you know they
protesters outside of clinics and then
they have like a clinic escort to meet
you at your car so like none of the
protesters like attack you they wear
like an orange vest okay so yeah they
have like
in places where it's really bad like the
clinic will have someone stand outside
and come get you from your car and there
was a bunch of protesters in the city
escort came over to get the girl from
her car and as she's walking over it
turns out that the clinic escort is
actually one of the protesters like
wearing a vest and she was screaming at
this girl is so sad like in like this
season is awful and I'm about to trash
it but I thought that was a really like
great like just learning teachable
moment for America the season is so
awful Jackie half of the episode is
something that happened six months ago
and half of it is something that
happened now and so they go back and
forth with like six months from now six
months ago with different colored like
lenses I get super bright when it's like
past and then it's dark when it's now
it's unbelievably confusing it is it is
the worst it is awful like it is [ __ ]
trash nothing makes sense they just
decided to put a third season together
and like put some [ __ ] together and pray
for the best
it's [ __ ] awful Margo you're good
we're good you're good okay our two
great was that the final story that was
the fifth and final story to share a
personal update that I have decided to
stay in my apartment I know I was like
going back and forth with all the jobs
I've just decided that the treachery of
moving is not one I want to you know
incur incur because there's just I've so
much clutter I have so much stuff
everywhere I just I don't even think I
could begin to to wrap my head around it
you know yeah but if I did decide to and
I did look into like you know a couple
options if we're moving and decluttering
and if I'm clutter which I did want to
share with everyone because whether
you're moving to a new place having a
baby or just Marie Kondo in your life
you're probably looking to free up some
space Self Storage is always an option
but it's anything but convenient what if
there's a way to store your valley bills
without breaking the bank or your back
well now there is meat clutter the
world's largest on-demand storage
provider when it comes to making life
easier clutter is the undefeated champ
there on-demand experience take the self
out of stuff storage with clutter
finding an affordable place to stash
your things is a never been simpler just
sit back relax and let clutter take care
of the rest it's the world's largest
full-service on-demand storage
experience there's no guesswork in no
wasted space clutter helps you find out
just how much storage you need it's zero
effort you schedule to pick up with
clutter they'll be there to pack up and
move your belongings into their secure
facility the best part is clutters price
match guarantee means you get the lowest
possible monthly storage rate need your
stuff on it clutter will just bring it
I adore like literally could it be
easier and so because I'm having like
some construction down my floors I don't
need to move out but I do need to move
some furniture out and I don't know
where I would put it like in the hallway
like yeah so this was the perfect
solution but they literally come pick it
up I only need it gone for a week um
there well it might end up being more
because you know construction
contractors are always saying one thing
and then doing another so I don't get
any their sanding my floor so I don't
get any dust all over my furniture then
they just put my furniture right back I
thought it was the perfect solution
that's what I need for Zach because he's
a hoarder and he won't throw stuff away
oh and like it'll just be like two
soul-crushing for me to make him throw
things away but like clutter and come
snatch it up it'll be waiting for him
whenever he actually needs it clutter is
a great sign of bonus for our listeners
get $50 off your first month when you
sign up at clutter calm slash toast and
for existing storage users switch to
clutter for 30% off your more monthly
charge bill
so that's on top of clutters no hassle
moving online inventory management free
pickup and delivery and price match
guarantee see why clutter is better and
get $50 off your first month at clutter
CLU tter dot-com slash toast
that's clutter calm slash toasts and
enter promo code toast TOA st at
checkout this is one of the brands i
never would have heard about if not for
the choice and I'm so unbelievably
grateful because in situations like this
when you just have to move shuck jive
and like your whole life is shaken up
it's nice to have a partner that you can
really appreciate I agree TOA st i was
like very smug clutter well then you
know Jojo C was dream tour diarchy a.m.
that's her song yes hey I'm he gonna do
a remix that's so I didn't even know
that about her she's been quiet - she's
on tour another fella touring act
she's been chain-smoking her way through
the country she's stomping her way the
giant Jojo sequel she doesn't even need
a tour bus she just takes like a baby
steps and she's there for Jojo Siva one
smell it's it's one big step for mankind
one very small Stephanie I don't see
what she's on tour killing it she played
The Beacon Theater - is this whole chord
and quit her song it's called dream and
it's the dream tour and it's like the
pinnacle of her show and she has like
this dance move for when she does the
part in the song and it's like it's a
divine CA it's like hey come here
yourself it looks really good wow I need
to adjust see where's the show maybe
Northwest you do you should you should
check out the competition like she's
technically like you're like yeah yeah
younger you sir she's the Hannah Montana
of our generation and as someone who was
the aspiring Hannah Montana of our
generation it's devastating to watch no
but you should definitely see what the
usurpers up to dren
well just a show for you guys I hope you
enjoyed it it was a nice short a quickie
I feel like no an hour it's actually
been 57 minutes so I was gonna try to
talk for three more minutes to make it a
full hour yeah because I I know people
love when they see like in the podcast
episode yeah 1 : 0 0 is so much better
than 59 coletek you talking so that
people think at that um ok well if you
want to head over to girl with no job
calm I got a bunch of shows coming up
and it's such a relief to have to
promote shows like so over the summer
ticket sales are much slower so like I
was constantly like shelling tickets
girl they know now my shows up until
January told the tour it's over I like
mostly sold out it's I can't tell you
like what a relief and it's like to go
into a city not have to worry about
selling tickets you know I imagine it's
like how ariana grande feels 100% or how
Taylor Swift is gonna feel yeah it feels
so good girls no job calm our drunk get
ready with me that we're still suffering
the consequences from is up at
patreon.com slash the morning toast it
is 50 minutes of truly premium content
like it was okay this is gonna be a long
week you guys to get to that holiday
weekend so I recommend becoming a patron
today if you're not already speaking of
the holiday weekend Jackie and I are
headed to Dallas for Labor Day weekend
I'm weekly would know if you've already
saw our video I'm just you know
infringing on her plans I was just
thinking what do I don't want to do for
Labor Day weekend I do not want to go to
the Hamptons it'd just be like an
another thirst monster at the surf Lodge
so I decided to crush your plans and
sandwich a key we're going to Rascal
Flatts concert that's so exciting
so there will be no show Friday right
there will be no show Friday because we
are traveling right in Monday so we're
taking a long weekend you should too I'm
get a white clock laws law and we have
one more patron episode coming on coming
up this month that we're gonna film
which was Claudius genius idea I think
it was so cheap you've been thinking
about it and how we have to make radio
personality that's like a radio show and
I was a jingle to I was seeing like Jack
and Claud in the mornings you know there
is already Kyle and Jackie O which is
like a really famous I think it's
Australian radio show and like that
we're a little too similar you know like
Kyle Claudia Jackie yeah that's weird oh
yeah okay so we'll have to see Jamie
won't like it
radio morning radio personalities are
the most energy remember wouldn't Khloe
Kardashian had a radio show club after
dark or something oh my 101 choose Miami
wow by the way her co-host was Michael
yo right the comedian I think I don't
know maybe it's me that I'm interested
interesting fact that was such weird
times that was and then she also had
your show like cocktails because she
really has she tried enough like the
rest of us yeah and she landed in a
great spot of revenge body and an
American good American yes um okay so it
was good waste of two minutes the Emma
dies I still don't think we hit that one
well if I do my my nice drawn-out exists
okay that's right it's are going slower
than usual but before you do your
Drummond exit like definitely follow me
on instagram instagram Akama saw Jackie
O problems like really premium premium
stuff
premium premium premium premium premium
content so thank you so much for
watching the Millenial morning show the
morning toast what the money toast is
big alive Monday through Friday 10:30
a.m. Eastern Time on YouTube so if
you're watching on YouTube right now
give this video a thumbs up subscribe
you want to tell your friends about it's
just the millennium morning show we talk
about fun things nothing too serious you
know a great community for fellow lovers
of pop culture it's just a good time and
and if you're a podcaster we're also
available as a podcast that's 11:30 um
on apple cider it may be like 59 so
let's just keep going
also the snatchler is the new greatest
podcast in the land it'll be up
Wednesday it'll be back on iTunes by
then we swear there's just been so much
controversy surrounding the snatcher
she's was snatching all the ratings they
snatched her downs
um but she'll be back by Wednesday so
make sure you find her and it has just
been announced that Miley Cyrus will
actually be performing at the VMAs when
she originally said she wasn't and she
says she's like yeah right away yeah
ain't your son and Taylor's performing
she's opening are you guys gonna watch
yes I'm gonna watch i watch hard eyes
tomorrow Snatchers not til Wednesday so
right time in award show on a Monday
night like crazy I thought it was I
thought it was last night and then I had
to do research and it wasn't oh because
they tried that last
they filmed it one night the movie
awards yeah where they filmed it and
then aired it not live yet the next day
weird I don't know but you know what I'm
out what's our singing do we know we'll
say it better be a new one anyway she's
gonna sing lover oh okay no ma I don't
know but the opening has to be like yeah
that's why it like you would think it
you need to calm down
nobody it would be a single yeah you
know alright we love you guys thank you
so much for watching we'll see you
tomorrow tomorrow I love ya tomorrow
you're only a day
a whole
where
a
you